[Music]
welcome to
session 52 of the worlds of speculative
fiction series this is a
now online series originally it was face
to face
in which we're looking at classic and
contemporary
speculative fiction which could be
fantasy in this case
is what we're looking at horror
sci-fi alternate history pick whatever
you want within that spectrum and for
the last two sessions we
have been looking at the first two books
in this trilogy by r scott backer the
prince of
nothing trilogy which is followed by
four other books in the same series in
the second apocalypse
we are now going to be discussing the
final and shorter work the thousand-fold
thought which is quite excellent
although not everybody
else necessarily agrees as we're going
to talk about
and so we've had two previous sessions
if you're really interested
in this series you might want to go back
to session 50
on the darkness that comes before and
session 51
on the warrior prophet so in this
session we're going to be looking
just at this work although i will
say that there are some points in this
that i'm going to bring out in just a
few minutes
where the rest of the series is
in some respect prefigured you know
backer is either writing something that
then he takes up
as a thread or he's already got in mind
some of the i won't even call them plot
points i'll say plot arcs and massive
important foundational ideas
running through the unholy consult
series that's going
or the great ordeal rather series that's
going to come
after this now the thousandfold thought
we're going to talk about backer zone
discussions of it
and some reviews in lieu of doing any
biographical stuff because we've already
done that earlier in session 50.
the book itself deserves a little bit of
talking about
just in terms of what's in it so
like the previous one
there's a long so this is 33 pages of
what has come before some nice summary
to
help you out with you know what's going
on and then
this book is a little bit different it's
it's a bit shorter
now shorter is a relative term right
compare it to
these two heavy tomes uh which weigh
in at uh oh we got 580 odd pages
and um in this case uh
600 pages right and the
the what 400 500
500 pages in this book seems a little
bit
less i should also point out that there
is an encyclopedia
glossary in this work as well which
begins on page
405 so you're really only getting only
400 pages of
discussion plot dialogue you know
day new months revelations and all that
but it's still 400 pages so that that's
quite a
lot compared to many fantasy novels
it's it's only short in comparison to
the longer
tomes that we had as part one and part
two
and that actually becomes a bone of
contention among some readers
i do want to point out that this
glossary is
is quite cool and if you go onto
websites where the
the terminology and characters and
ideas and lands and religions and
types of magic pick whatever you want
from this series is being talked about
it's really coming from this
encyclopedic
glossary and this is this is well worth
reading
just in its own right because there's
almost like a story that's being told
through it
there's actually an author's note too
and he says steeped in the classics in
rithi scholars commonly rendered names
in their shake farming goes on with that
and then
he also tells us the vast majority of
these proper names are simply
transliterated
and and what's really cool is it
concludes
this little author's note by saying
these would be the names
as drusis akamian knew them
and i kind of like that why because
akamian
is he he is a central character right as
is essemet
as is kanayo kenair as is
kel huss um but
in a way although calhouse is really
the character around whom everything
ultimately ends up revolving
akamian really is the most central
character
i would argue and we're seeing much of
this
if we're seeing it through anybody's
eyes we're really seeing it i would say
through a cameon and although
maybe supplemented by by knight and
estimate so
that's that's probably enough about the
book
itself let's let's talk about
before we look at the reviews let's talk
about
some of the prefigurations or
foreshadowings of the four books
yet to come that we find contained
in this book if we know to look for it
and before we do that
what i'm going to say is this is this is
actually been my third time
reading this book the very first time
reading it
you know you're wandering through it and
maybe picking up on half of what's going
on the second time you see a lot more
especially since you've already already
know where the book is going
the third time you grasp a lot
more than you did in the past so let's
talk about these
foreshadowings the great ordeal
is a set of four additional volumes
in this second apocalypse series that
are
written after the thousand-fold thought
and which are happening
starting 20 years afterwards right
and so there's a lot going on in those
i count four different places
in a thousand-fold thought where there
are you could call them forward
references
to or foreshadowings whatever you want
to call them premonitions
of what is going to be happening
in the great ordeal which is oriented
around
kell huss now the aspect emperor of the
three c's
taking a rather triumphant and more or
less
unified although there's a lot of
fissures and cracks
humanity and leading this
massive army and you know sorcery
you could call it reconstituted schools
thing
north to golgotha roth to try to
destroy the consult before they can
reawaken the
no god and so there's there's four
places in here
where what's going to happen is
i think being foreshadowed and i could
be wrong maybe there's
more maybe maybe these are just sort of
like backer himself
didn't build these in and just kind of
picked up on them later on he's like oh
this is a good idea i i kind of look at
it as
not quite prophecy and here we actually
see prefigured
you know this uh interesting discussion
that happened even in the first book
about
the uh the the notion that that kel huss
has
you know which he got from his uh the
people who've raised him
that there's this causal connection
and what goes before determines what
comes
afterward that prophecy can't can't
happen
and calhouse comes to realize that
that's not actually the case at least
within the narrative universe so
that's enough back and forth about this
and metaphysical speculation
what are these four points so one is
very early on
and this is coming through the eyes of
canard
who really is one of the people who
knows calhouse the best
the skill vendi who's who's traveled
with him
who had a previous encounter with
calhouse's father
mangus right so he says
can kanira found himself looking about
the chamber his breath tight in his
chest
quietly astounded that men wept rather
than jeered
and then for the first time the depths
of the dread purpose
that moved these men became palpable
he had seen it he had witnessed it on
the fields be
beyond karaskan's wall the lunatic
determination
enough to shame even his uttamat he had
watched men
vomit boiled grass as they stumbled
forward he'd seen others who could
scarce walk
throw themselves on the weapons of the
heathen just to disarm them
he had seen men smile cry out in joy as
the mastodons descended upon them
he could remember thinking that these
men these in rithi were the true
people of war now that's a huge thing of
course
because the skilvendi are the people of
war
right and so he says canair had seen it
but he had not
understood not fully what the
dunyan had wrought here would never be
undone
even if the holy war should perish the
word of these events would survive
inc would make this madness immortal
calhouse had given these men more than
gestures or promises
more even than insider direction he had
given them dominion
over their doubts over their most hated
foes he had made them
strong but how could lies
do such a thing the world these men
dwelt within was a fever dream a
delusion and yet it seemed as real to
them knowledge knew
as his world seemed to them the only
difference and kenair
was curiously troubled by the thought
was that he could in
meticulous detail track the origins of
their world within his
and only then because he knew the dunyan
of
all that congregated in this room he
alone knew the ground the treacherous
footing beneath
their foot so
this is you know telling us about what's
happening in this story and
actually what's happened in the pre the
two previous books
where calhous has managed to forge a
movement out of the raw material of the
holy war
in ruthism the notion of prophecy and
appealing to the the needs the desires
the demands the psychological depths
of the people who he's working with
right something greater is going to come
out of this
there's another passage a little bit
later where
um kenair has been assigned to this task
of
watching over the disarmed non-sir
and confus right and he says
he understood why kelhus wanted confused
dead
the dunyan suffered no rivals likewise
he understood why calhouse had chosen
him as his assassin
of course the savage had killed the lion
was he not scilventi
was he not a survivor of kieth so these
are talking about things that went
before
uh the battle of kaiuth which happens in
the the very first
book early on is where the skill vendi
are broken as a people um
kanye is one of the few skill vendi
chieftains who actually survives
and um this is what allows confus to
become not just exalt general
of of the non-sir the empire but
the possibility of the leader becoming
the leader is
he doesn't end up becoming of the
holy war and so
there's this rivalry going on there
right it would be natural for
calhouse to appoint um can
i hire to to be his tool
but then knight says here's in his
his uh thought what tormented him was
what these
understandings implied if murdering
mangus his father
was kelhus's sole mission then
preserving the holy war should be his
sole concern
why assassinate confus when he need only
remove him from the game as he had
and why use canirer to conceal his
involvement when the consequences open
war with the empire
would have no bearing on the imminent
conquest of shame this this holy city
that the entire holy war
has been oriented towards taking
and then can canaiyer realized there was
no way around it that dunyane was
looking beyond the holy war
pashame and to see pashame
was also to see past mengis
so you know this is very important as
well the the
story began in the you know
first book with mangus summoning his son
calhouse to come get him and then you
know there's all this
traveling that takes place and calhouse
falls in
with cnire who knows that he's a dunyan
and they travel and then they become you
know both of them
involved in the holy war the prince of
nothing rises to become the warrior
prophet
and kanir for a long time is the war
leader for that he even draws
men who imitate him they abandon their
own folk ways
and try to become skill vendi which he
thinks is kind of interesting
and all of this is oriented according to
kelvis to get down to chamele where his
dad is
and to assassinate his dad which both he
and can i or want to do maybe they have
to compete over who's going to get to do
it
here canair says aha this is not
really about killing dad
this is or even rejoining dad this is
about something going beyond this and
that is going to be the great ordeal as
we're going to find out
another really important interesting
prefiguration that i won't tell you that
much about
as i have with these others happens in
the dreams of akamian where he is
recounting
what happened in the first apocalypse
and this begins with one of his uh
things
with now kaiuti at his side a kamian
crouched in the darkness peering across
the yawning fall before them
for days they'd grope through the black
too terrified to dare
any light at times it seemed they
climbed through blackened lungs
so choked and multitudinous where the
tunnels the elbows their elbows bled
from crawling on their bellies
he's talking about the dreams of
ceswatha that all of the mandate
sorcerers
relive at night during the years of the
great investiture
the shrink had burrowed out from
golgotharoth
far beneath the armies camped across the
surrounding plains when the siege was
broken the consul had forgotten the
mines
thinking themselves invincible and why
would they not
so here's where we get to the
prefiguring the ordeal
the holy war called by ana surambor
kalamas against golgotharath had
dissolved
had dissolved in what acrimony
and cannibal pride and the unholy advent
was near so very near
now those words cannibal pride
that's going to be kind of important but
i'm not going to tell you exactly why
except that it has to do with the second
grade ordeal
and the shronk will play an important
role in that
as well now the final one
is happening towards the very end of the
book near near the
uh you know they've they've actually
finished with with a whole bunch of uh
plot points and things like that
and this is when calhous and mangus are
talking to each other and
[Music]
here we go this is a very
interesting point so kel huss says the
crimes you've committed father the sins
when you learn of the damnation that
awaits you
when you come to believe you will be no
different than the incaroi
as dunyan you will be compelled to
master the consequences of your
wickedness
like the consult you will come to see
tyranny in what is holy
and you will war as they were so this is
kelhus talking to somebody who is
dunyane who is his father who has
managed to become
somebody warring against the consult but
he's saying
you will be in the same boat as the
consult
kelhus fell back into himself open his
deeper soul to the details of his
father's nearly naked form the strength
of limbs the speed of reflex
and then he says to shut the world
against the outside
to seal it through the extermination of
mankind this is his father talking and
then
kel huss replies as issual is shut
against the wilderness
for the dunyan it was axiomatic what was
compliant had to be
isolated from what was unruly and
intractable
calhous had seen it many times wandering
the labyrinth of possibilities that was
the thousand-fold
thought right the rise of
us on a suramar to take his place the
apocalyptic conspiracies the counterfeit
war against golgotharoth
the accumulation of premeditated
disasters sacrifice of whole nations to
the gluttony
of the srank the three seas crashing
into char
and ruin and so he can see what his
father would do
or what the what the dunyan themselves
would do and he's going to do something
different but if you read
the four books yet to come
you'll see that this passage
is actually prefiguring what's going to
happen to the dunyan
themselves in relation to the consult so
these are some pretty important
you could say foreshadowings whatever
you want to call them they're also going
to play
an important role within this text
itself
i would like to spend a bit of time
perhaps not as much as i did in the
previous sessions
talking about some reviews of the
thousand-fold thought and
not just reading them but noting what's
important in them
and what some of the reviewers might
have missed
and then i want to talk a bit about what
what our scott backer in
in one interview has to say about the
thousand-fold
thought and some of his you know writing
processes and reflections on his own
work
so the first review is in ssf
sff 180 and it's by thomas wagner and
these are
these reviews are all near in time to
the release
of the thousand-fold thought right
he says in the thousand-fold thought our
scott backer comes so close to being
crushed under the weight of his literary
ambitions
you almost jump for joy to see him
emerge at the end of it relatively
unscathed
he's done a really he's dared a really
great deal in constructing this trilogy
and he's broken virtually every rule
fantasy fans have come to expect
these are on general principal good
things some of backers choices have
amounted to biting off more than he can
chew but so what his willingness to do
it is admirable enough
that when all the smoke from this book's
breathless chapters is cleared
you'll be happy to give the guy a big
hand now you know do i buy
into that i think it's that's a little
bit overblown
perhaps i think backers a bit more you
know
competent in handling these things
then he goes on and he says backer's
choice to tackle such weighty themes
does
sometimes make his book slow moving
difficult expository
it's fair to say that not a lot actually
happens
in much of this final volume which can
seem kind of a letdown considering we've
been plowing through a thousand pages
waiting for this massive holy war to
reach its gory
and climax backer lets the first half of
this book take its
sweet time we get some pompous
speechifying the motivations and desire
lines of his characters often lack focus
or apparent sense
but when backer pulls out the stops in
the last hundred pages the resulting
flash flood of action is spectacular
enough to offset the mildly
disappointing fact that the resolution
of
calhouse's primary goal the meeting with
his father mengis and the culmination of
the saga's themes is played out mostly
through dialogue
backer intercuts their scenes with
gloriously chaotic moments of battle
that often play out like a
hieronymous bosch painting come to
hellish life
it makes for one of the most freakishly
unput downable conclusions to a fantasy
trilogy i've read in a long time
so i think that's partly right and i
think that's partly
mistaken and i'm not going to say partly
wrong but i will say partly mistaken
because i think that the reviewer in
this case
is it's the sort of thing i might have
said on a first read of this
but not after re-reading it so there's
something to
actually spending time with it that
helps you to
fill in the gaps i don't buy that very
little is happening in the first half of
it
very little is happening if we're
primarily focused on the proceeding of
the holy war
if we're also interested in what's
happening in the
minds of these characters particularly
essent akamian and kanir
there's a lot that's happening and
actually we're learning a lot about the
consult as well
in this volume perhaps more than we did
in
the previous two through what's what's
actually going on
and there's some important jockeyings
and some you know people getting uh
you know elevated brought down think
about the scarlet spires
and um their grand master realizing
holy crap these prophecies are actually
true
we're we're not at the center of things
we're actually kind of a side note
and then he's getting his his school
ready to fight against the cicero
towards the the very end so i don't
think that this is
actually right except i will say that
there is
you know as they're catapulting into the
final action
there is a lot going on speech fine
philosophizing
that's important for this right let's go
on to the next one this is from uh
jamie james davies in fantasy faction
it is not a bad book more a novel that
i'm not sure back or knew what to do
with it seems to be part apocalyptic
showdown
parts set up for the next trilogy giving
it a very cloudy identity as to what on
earth it's trying to get across
obviously bocker originally envisioned
it as the climax of his first novel in
that sense it might have worked very
well but as its own novel it suffers
quite considerably i feel
let's talk about that climax this is
about the last quarter of the book with
the exception of the very last 10 or so
pages
backer unfortunately seems to have
thought that
to have exciting pacing he would have to
flip between
five different plot threads at the rate
of a beam of light caught between five
reflections
nice pros there isn't it probably a page
is spent with one character before your
thrust to another then again
and then again this must go on for at
least 50 pages if not more and it truly
gets to the point where you lose
focus on what is going on completely
this is definitely the case for one such
thread
which revolves around deep philosophical
debate
between two powerful characters and
there he's talking about
you know the two uh dunyan
right calhouse and his father mengis
flitting in and out of this conversation
so much caused me to completely lose
track of the flow of the conversation
and i feel it's true meeting was lost on
me
this was a damn shame backer's flow of
writing is
quality as usual but his choice to
sacrifice that quality for pacing
was wrong now again this is one of those
things where
i would be more inclined to go along
with it
if two things were not the case if i was
not reading this for the you know second
and third time
and if i didn't understand why the
philosophy
stuff mattered i think that it it might
be hard for some
some readers to get as easy a grasp
because backer really is a philosophical
writer
on what's happening in some of these
dialogues with the characters
particularly when it gets really
metaphysical right
as it does between the two
dunyan in this uh i think it might be a
little bit harder to follow i think that
could be a fair
charge but there's so much exposition
given and the glossary i think would
would help somebody now you know some
some people pointed out that why do you
have to go to a glossary well you could
say the same thing though about like you
know martin or tolkien right
uh davies goes on and he says
the slower character moments in the
stories of akamian
assamet calhouse and kanir which were
always the best parts of these novels
continue to shine with some intensely
moving moments
in the story the last scene in
particular is marvelous and potentially
one of the best closings of a novel i've
come across
the stage set is grand in its potential
consequences and the character
development painfully inevitable
but wonderfully portrayed it's a
wonderful setup for the next trilogy if
a somewhat
lackluster ending for the current one
the reason i write this is purely due to
the number of plot lines still left wide
open at the end of this book
with barely a story concluded
satisfactorily
so there's really two things going on in
this this discussion right one
is he's right
backer is leaving all sorts of plot
lines open
so that he can explore them in the books
to come that's completely true
and if that's you know if that's
something that makes this novel not as
good
well you know so be it i do think that
he's really on to something though and
saying the slower character moments
um continue to shine with intensely
moving moments in the story so
this guy gets it gets what wagner was
not
getting the last one rob bedford
in sff world in a thousand fold thought
we see calhouse
more through the eyes of his supporting
cast this really allows the reader to
feel the awe
reverence and fear these people feel for
the warrior prophet
as he leads his holy war across the
landscape of the three seas
the primary characters remain the same
essemet
uh drusa sakamian and kanire
there are many more older characters
plus one or two new characters featured
prominently in this volume each of these
characters sees calhouse in their own
light
but each light is a different reflection
of on which they hold the warrior
prophet i think
that's quite true that's a great insight
into what's going on here
now he goes on and he says while
calhouse may be a center around which
these characters orbit by no means is he
the only character with such a powerful
effect on the other characters
take the former lovers essent and akka
they loved each other and still do
but they do not understand the depths of
each other's emotions until they were
apart
particularly when essent realizes how
akka felt about her
and i i think that's that's very
insightful as well
he goes on and he says one thing that
really struck me regardless of whether
or not the scene was straightforward
action dialogue between characters
or internal dialogue of discovery
backer's narrative pull was equally
strong
many of the tightly crafted and
addictive scenes involved one character
in their internal dialogue estimate
re-examines her life through the
majority of the novel
that's very true especially now that
she's able to read
that opens an entire world right in the
previous volume zaca struggled with the
realization of the prophecies long
considered coming to light
in his ultimate role as adviser to the
man at the center of the prophecy
through this re-examination estimate
grows to know
her former lover providing for some of
the more poignant and powerful scenes
not just in this particular novel but in
any of the fantasy novels i've come
across
and really i would say that leads to the
final
conclusion with the scene where where
akka
repudiates all of these
things i think without the estimate seen
in there there's no
there's no actual repudiation that takes
place
and bedford goes on to say indeed this
entire trilogy
deals with inner reflection perhaps more
so than any of the contemporaries
on the shelves i don't know if that's
the case but
it certainly does a lot consideration of
one's inner self and outer self only
touch the tip of the iceberg of the many
thoughtful considerations the warrior
prophet drives the characters and then
turned the reader to
consider right
so that's that's actually a really great
set of
insights i think that these there's
other reviews out there that you can
check out but
those are probably the best ones that i
came across
with a living author and one who has
been so
online until fairly recently for so much
of the progress of the stories coming
out i'd be very remiss to not
actually bring back or into the mix with
at least
one interview and so this is one from
sff world right
and some of these questions are really
quite interesting especially the
responses to him so he was asked
given the complexity of many of your
characterizations is there a character
you particularly enjoyed
and or enjoyed writing why is that is
there also a character you absolutely
don't like writing about
and backer says there's no one i'd
really dislike
writing it's more a matter of each
posing their peculiar challenges
at particular points now i really like
that because what he's doing is taking a
binary
you know like don't like and turning it
into a more contextual thing each of
them has their challenges
because each of them is not a living
being but at least something coming out
of my head
that i need to work with and he says
kelhus is typically the most difficult
because it's hard to convincingly
portray someone that damn smart
others i er oscillate between extreme
difficulty and
writing themselves i had expected he
would be the most difficult
after kel huss to write in the
thousand-fold thought
but thanks to the melvins and lustmore
he ended up writing himself
right the bands right confis is easily
my favorite now isn't that a funny thing
to say
and we've talked about this in previous
sessions where backers talked about why
he liked
writing confis he says sometimes i laugh
my ass off
writing his his sections and confess is
you know
this character is kind of full of
himself but has some reasons to be full
of himself
and is kind of a you know weird guy
but also attractive in many respects
a little bit later he's asked what do
you feel is your strength as a
writer or storyteller and backer says
this question is hard because i
still feel i have so much to learn i
think my strength is that i set myself
explicit challenges for myself extreme
challenges in some case
for each scene i always ask myself what
i want my words to do
most times i fall short of my goals
sometimes i satisfy them and every once
in a while
like the scene i call essemet's song in
the thousand-fold thought
i sit back and think there's no way i
wrote that now that's also some very
interesting reflections there i think
from
the author he was asked again what would
you say was the hardest part of the
entire process involved
in writing the prince of nothing each
new addition reveals yet more depth to a
series which has shown just how rich and
complex it truly is
what was the spark that generated the
idea which drove you to write the series
in the first place and so
here backer talks at greater length he
says
i could go on and on about the
complexities i just spent so much time
layering things into the world and story
it almost feels geological when i think
about it
the framework arose from my attempt to
make good on all the work i put into my
dnd campaigns back in the 80s
the story proper grew around the
character of calhouse
who arose from the biggest revelation i
suffered in my first year of university
back in 1986 the realization that belief
systems are more
a product of social function than of
truth
so here's where it gets really
interesting
standing inside a given belief system
canonical claims always seem obviously
true so much so that we
reflexively use them as the yardstick of
other belief systems
while remaining utterly oblivious to the
fact that others are doing the exact
same thing with the same depth of
conviction
we seem to forget that having conviction
no matter how soulful or meaningful or
redemptive is as much an indicator of
deception
as it is of accuracy ignorance is
invisible after all
thanks to psychological mechanisms like
confirmation bias fundamental
attribution error and
self-exceptionalism we're quite content
with
the embarrassing notion that we somehow
just locked on to the one true belief
system and
and why not when it's the only yardstick
that we have
everything else has to come up short
outsiders are judged and found
wanting when you consider
the pivotal role belief plays in action
and the way social systems depend on the
repetition of interrelated actions to
exist
he says then you can see that the
primary function of belief systems is to
conserve
actions not to be true this is why
social systems collapse when belief in
them collapses which is arguably what
happened in the old soviet union
given things like this i asked myself
what a martial artist who used the
functionality of belief
as well as his swords and his hands
would look like and i came up with
calhous
and i think that's part of the story
there right because the other thing that
backer is doing is entering
not just creating calhous which is an
interesting project
in its own right and and a serious
challenge right because
all the things we've talked about
already but again those
those three other really absolutely
central
characters through whom we have so much
exposition
and there's so much development akamian
essemet kenair each of them
is also living within belief systems but
also
skeptical about those belief systems and
trying to make sense of themselves
there's a lot of reflection going on
maybe more reflection on their part than
there even is on
kel huss's part even though he possesses
the thousand-fold
thought so that's that's an interesting
set of ideas and now it's time for us to
actually
explore some some philosophical themes
that will largely be centered around the
action and the characters
uh but there's a lot of scope for
exploring that
in this final novel in this series
it is quite fitting that we begin
with a grand theme of endings for
a trilogy that is ending right here in
my hand with a thousand-fold thought and
particularly
a trilogy which doesn't have an awful
lot of
epilogue once the final conflicts have
been
worked out and there's still a number of
threads as one of the reviewers pointed
out
left to be tugged to be
to be tied to as is going to happen in
the four
follow-up books but there's a lot of
things that are actually coming to an
a nice fairly neat close
by the end of this so we can talk in
particular
about kell huss and his connection with
his father
mengis also about connier and
because because both calhouse and kenair
have been seeking out
mengis and there is a resolution there a
very important resolution that we're
going to
talk about in different ways we can also
talk about
a very very dramatic resolution for
acamian and that's at the very end of
this story so we're going to get to that
shortly and we can talk about the end of
the
holy war itself all of these
men of the tusk and the great names
and the emperor the
you know at one time excellent general
now
emperor as we're going to see betraying
the holy war
um and also we can talk about essmet and
and her relationship with calhouse and
the ending of her relationship
with akamian and coming into her own as
as well so there's a lot of
stuff getting brought to a
close here and we have to trace all of
those endings out there's other
philosophical themes that we'll explore
as well but this will probably take us a
little bit of time so i want to begin
with confus who has betrayed the holy
war
and in the narrative looks like he might
actually
cause the failure at cheme
because things are so close between the
phoneme and the men of the tusk the ine3
uh the followers of calhous and and now
the
emperor confis has taken that
that role is about to stab them in the
back
and he says astride his horse the
emperor gazed down the
initial encampment out to where sheme
smoked and flickered with warring lights
in addition to the ailing psych grand
master general
aria monterres several sundry officers
and
members of the messenger corps
accompanied him a raid along the summit
of the mounted ridge his kid reholes
those
heavy cavalry fanned out before him
forming ranks lower on the slopes near a
series of ruined
structures he couldn't be troubled to
identify his columns
the infantry approached from behind
already drawn into red and gold battle
lines
their timing had been impeccable they
depart from the fleet the night before
in a miraculous little harbor mirror
miles up the cor
the coast even the winds had been
blessed and now
he fairly cackled at what he saw the
scarlet spires engaged
in the shadow of the jedi room half the
holy war was running heedless and amuck
through the smoking streets fennel
striking to the south of the city trying
to
outflank the stubborn tydoni everything
was exactly as his scouts
had informed him the men of the tusk had
no inkling of his arrival
which meant that sompas wherever he was
had succeeded in stopping the skill
vendi
four full columns a veritable spear
in the small of the holy war's back
and he's he he laughs and he says this
is going to be
amazing and then something happens
akamian shows up and akamian remember is
a sorcerer of the mandate he is armed
with the gnosis
which can tear apart the lesser sorcery
of the anagonistic and agnostic schools
like the psych or you know the scarlet
spires for that matter
and he says
confused found and recognized the man
immediately drewsus
akamian walking through the grass
turning toward him his eyes and mouth
ablaze engaging in his sorcery
groping for his corey he screamed
kikamet
but heat sucked all air from his lungs
he heard screams dissolved like salt
into boiling broth he was falling
to me emperor an aged voice cried to me
he was on the ground rolling through
grasses that had become black ash
somehow the grandmaster of the imperial
psych was standing above
him his white hair whipping in
convections his sorceress voice strong
despite his unsteady stance ethereal
ramparts distorted the air between them
and the mandate sorcerer
who turned to the breaking ranks of
kidrahul lines of light swept out more
perfect than any rule
flashing across the nearest of the
imperial heavy cavalry who collapsed not
bodily
but in sopping pieces that rolled
between the hummocks and the weeds so
akhmanian is doing something that he's
sort of threatened to do all of this
time which is to let loose the gnosis
on these these people and
what we see end up happening is he
destroys the psych he destroys
these these things and then he ahmanian
is actually
seized by a sit frank a demon that takes
him
away here we go
and the monstrosity
leapt into the sky punishing the air
with rent wings
estimate sees this happening and then
confess recovers
i live it curry confess cried one more
time only to hear nothing above the
crack and thunder of sorceress battle
both near and far
no resounding cheer no individual shouts
of relief or
acclaim they couldn't see him that was
it they mistook him for one of their own
for a man because he believes himself to
be a god
and so he brings his troops back into
line
find some horsemen tell them to signal
the general advance
grinning he turned back to the vista of
his army
only to see the horseman he'd glimpsed
earlier several hundred of them riding
unchallenged along the stationary flanks
of the cellular column there are no
nations there are no more nations
uh voice cried and then uh confis
says kill them attack attack attack
right
so he's going to betray them one more
time
and then he says the white clad knight's
abruptly changed direction began riding
towards him
confidence turned to the remaining
column areas at once laughed and snarled
um going further down here of the dozen
nancer column columnaries who faced him
two fell to their knees
weeping three offered their swords five
ran like mad men and two simply walked
away
he reminds them i defeated the skill
vendi you were there
and then they kiss his imperial ring
and then what happens after that the
emperor
of non-surturn not really believing he
saw a king
sow button leaning from his saddle his
face ruddy with murderous intent
more than sun glinted in the man's blue
eyes he saw the broad sword that took
his head
and that is the end of contrast that is
the end of the non-sir empire
that is the end of that and that is the
beginning
of salbon's redemption
which is going to carry through into
the four books that follow so there's
there's a
nice tying things up proyes of course
is another very important uh great name
that's going to be
tied in with this as well so that's one
line
of very important ending
we get to see the end of knight but not
the true end of him because he is going
to continue forward as an important
character
in the four volumes yet to come but we
get to see his
resolution of what he's been
about what he's been aiming for after
calhouse leaves his wounded father
and mengis and caniyer encounter
each other so
what we what we see depicted here is the
skill vendi gagged for breath
there he was slumped against the mad
walls of this place in a white
illuminated chamber that opened at the
end of the corridor
pale naked save a loincloth there he was
for hours knight had climbed through
these halls following
cervez and her brother as they tracked
calhouse's scent
apart from the braziers beneath the
cavernous waterfall all had been black
deep into dark deep darkened to dark
through an underworld of vile
images they passed through ruins sirway
said the minds of the kunaroy
long murdered by the ancestors of men
and canair had known no track could lead
him farther
from the step his heart had hammered in
his ears
he had glimpsed his father skiotha
beckoning through the black and now
there
he was mangus the object of his
revenge so
he stops cerave and her brother
and then here here we go the uh
throughout this canyon advanced down the
corridor walking steadily through the
numbness of his gate made it seem he
shambled he remembered approaching
calhouse the same way the day that he'd
found him half dead on his father's
barrow
surrounded by circles of lifeless shrank
he remembered the limb hollowing air of
nightmares the breath like needles but
this was different
that had been the point of departure
from his homeland
from his people from everything he
thought hallowed and strong
this was his destination this was him
the the person who had taken him off the
path
to begin with and
here we go nyu the blind face said in
recognition
calhouse's voice tell calhouse's
features when had the sun become the
father's mold
now you have returned to me just as i
knew
you would so he's talking to him in this
familiar diminutive
term he says nyu put down your sword
please and then he says
i am knighter or urs scaltha the most
violent of men
and mangus says no that is but a lie
that you use to conceal your weakness
from other men just as weak
kanir says it is you who lie and then
manga says
but i see it within you i see the truth
of you i see your
love i hate he screamed so loud the
walls return the words to him in a
thousand whispers
though blind meng has somehow managed to
look to the ground in pensive pity
so many years so many seasons everything
i showed you has scarred your heart set
you apart from the people
now you hold me accountable for what i
taught
why does it torment you so surely lies
when uncovered fade like smoke it is
truth that burns naya as you know for
you have burned in it for uncounted
seasons
and he goes on me
and and kaniah says
he loved him this man who had shown him
who'd let him on to the trackless step
manga says i am dying now you i need
your strength
and knight thinks to himself he had
loved
only him in all the world weeping [ __ ]
the kiss was deep the smell strong his
heart hammered shame
bled from his every pore skittered
across his trembling limbs
and somehow ignited an even deeper ardor
what does he do he grips him
and takes out the korah and he says
i wander trackless ground so
he's he's absorbed the lessons he's
finally
figured things out and he's going to
with the
the korah the tear of god that kills
sorcerers
that turns him into salt he's going to
destroy
finally the one who he's been seeking
all of this time and then mangus gasped
jerked and spasmed as
caniya rolled the korai across his cheek
white light flared from his gouge
sockets
for an instant kaner thought it seemed
as though the god watched him through a
man's skull
but then his lover fell away burning as
he must such was the force of what had
possessed him
is this a resolution well we see canair
says not again
he howled at the sagging form he
stumbled to his knees weaving raping
how could you leave me
and he laughed thinking of the final
swaziland he would cut into his throat
killing himself right one last thought
to many
see see he cackled with grief he knelt
over his lover's corpse for how many
heartbeats he would never know
then just as the sorceress light began
to fade a cool hand fell
on his cheek he turned and saw survey
for an instant her face cracked as
though gasping for air but then it was
seamless once again seamless and
perfect yes stairway the first wife of
his heart his proof
and prize absolute darkness engulfed
them
and now he is ready to join the consult
completely but still as knighter
not as a agent of the consult but
somebody who
aligns with him and that's that's where
he ends
the end and the resolution for akamian
is in some respects a long time coming
and there's more that we need to say
about his relationship as it develops
with kell huss at the very beginning
in in this chapter karaskand um
there's this important phrase here
akamian realized
that this was year one a new age of
men he says while waiting for the hidden
machinery of messengers and secretaries
to relay his request
akamian wandered into an adjoining
courtyard struck by the other
immensities that framed his present
circumstance even if there was no
consult
no threat of the second apocalypse he
realized
nothing would be the same calhus would
change the world
not in the way of an agence or a triamus
but in the way of an inri saganus so
as a prophet as we're going to see
not just as a prophet not just as a king
not just as a warrior
not just as a philosopher not just
as a sorcerer not just as the
shaman right who combines
sorcerer and and prophet
but as an aspect emperor which has a
very important
role in this and year one
means that everything is beginning again
with with him so akamian
after he you know is released uh is
walking back and comes into the presence
of the court this is a very important
scene
all were kneeling as he passed through
the outer ring of pillars
pressing through their murmuring mitts
he found himself thinking of the strange
hollow that had opened within him he
stood he breathed which meant his heart
still beat within
his breast but its pulse was lost to him
he thought of all the lies that would
soon spill from his scalp
right because he's about to die then he
recognized the voice of
mythonet the holy sheerah of the
thousand temples
arise on a surambhur calhouse for all
authority now resides in thee
a moment of silence behold the warrior
prophet the obscured shira bellowed
behold the high king of kuniri
behold the aspect emperor of the
three seas the words winded
akamian as surely as a father's blow
while the men of the tusk leapt to their
feet crying out in rapture and
adaptation
he staggered against one of the white
pillars feeling the cool of engraved
figures
pressed against his neck what
was this hollow that had so consumed him
what was the yearning that felt so like
mourning here he's remembering
the words of knight who knows the secret
of the dunyan
they make us love they make us love
some time passed before he realized
calhouse himself was speaking
akamian found himself drawn forward
dressed in the silk collets other
enemy things and knights pressed clear
of his path staring as though he were
a leper now here's an important speech
by calhouse
with me everything is rewritten your
books
your parables and your prayers all that
was your custom are now
nothing more than childhood curiosities
for too long
has truth language in the vulgar hearts
of men what you call tradition is not
but artifice
the fruit of your vanity of your lust of
your fear and your hate
with me all souls shall find a more
honest footing
with me all the world is born anew
year one actually let's pause on that a
moment and think about
what this means we've seen this theme
coming up previously
that a person could be truth incarnate
rather than just
a mere possessor of the truth
and the truth that is calhous
which behind the scenes is actually
there's a different truth
and he is revealing he's working off of
the falsehoods that
humans believe in but they think that
they have now grasped the truth this is
going to remake
everything all the things that they have
believed so deeply he can transfer the
power
the force the meaning from the
prophets from the philosophers even
perhaps from sorcery
itself and its relationship with the
metaphysics
of of his world into
something that becomes available right
there
and if you think about the difference
between that and what
phanemery which is kind of a
prefiguration of it the solitary god
fought him as his prophet was was
providing to people no longer this
mediated through the thousand temples of
the many different gods
you know the god within all of these
rather abstract
and then you know particularized
calhous is taking that place and he's
doing it
as a human being
somebody that can be engaged with
somebody who can be loved
somebody who can be obeyed
so they're at the holy court of the
aspect emperor now
he saw mythonets draped in the gold
investments of a station he saw proust
salman all the other surviving lords of
the holy war a new caste nobility
less numerous but more radiant than the
old he saw the niskenti
and other high-ranking apparati of the
ministry decked in the glory of their
fraudulent station
he saw now now zera and the quorum
flashing crimson gold in the mandate's
finest ceremonial robes
he even saw yokos standing as pale as
glass and a liazeras
magisterial gown so he's seeing
the the new nobility he's
seeing the niskenti all of these are the
followers
he's seeing his own school of sorcery
he's seeing the other main school at
this point in time
the scarlet spires represented
then he sees estimate her mouth open her
painted eyes shining with tears
that spilled a nilmaneshi empress once
again so this woman
who began as a prostitute a harlot
in the holy city who he loved but
couldn't marry
who he found again they loved again
then she thought him dead and became the
consort
of calhouse and there's this divide
between them
he sees her he says
he could not see stairway he could not
see kenai or confuse
neither was exemanus anywhere to be
found
all of them are dead or vacant but he
saw
calhous leonine before a great hanging
circumflex of white and gold
going on he sees he saw him drawing the
nets of the future
measuring theorizing categorizing
penetrating he saw the dunyan
kel huss nodded to him this is what i
decree aka the old world is dead
leaning against his staff akamian so you
speak
of an apocalypse and then
he's told come take your place at my
side it would be so simple
for a kamian to now fit in
and he's been the vizier he's been the
teacher the royal tudor
but he doesn't do that he says no
i've returned for my wife nothing more
a moment of crushing monolithic silence
preposterous now zero to cried out you
will do as he recommends
even though akamian heard the grand old
sorcery did not heed him
years had passed since he last
understood his scholastic brothers
he held out his hand so he's engaging in
an absolute existential gesture there
s me he watched her find her feet saw
the crescent of her belly she
was showing how could he not have seen
that before
calhouse simply watched you're a mandate
schoolman now sarah graded with
admirable menace
a mandate schoolman trying to remind him
of of his
his responsibilities s me akhmanian said
his eyes outstretched hand directed only
at her please
this was the only thing that could mean
anymore for akamian
akka she sobbed she glanced around
seemed to wilt beneath the wrap gazes
i'm the mother of
of and here we get to the the
climax the crux the turning point
so the hollow could not be shut akamian
nodded
wiped the last tear he knew he would
ever shed he would be heartless now a
perfect man
a perfect man like the dunyan right she
approached him
the world akka don't you see the very
world hangs in the balance
with a savagery that both thrilled and
frightened emmy snatch her left wrist
twisted and bent it back so she could
see the blurred tattoo that black in the
back of her hand
she thrust he thrust her away from her
the crowd erupted in outrage no estimate
shrieked from the floor leave him alone
leave him you don't know him you don't
know
and then akamian says his renunciations
i renounce
akamian roared i renounce my station
as holy tutor as vizier to the court of
the
anna sirember kelhus i renounce my
school he continued
as an assembly of hypocrites and
murderers
now sarah says then you re you re
sentence yourself to death
there's no sorcery outside the schools i
renounce my
prophet gasps and sputters
filled the galleries of the first temple
he waited for the upper to subside
steering for what seemed an unblinking
eternity at the otherworldly aspect of
ana sirember calhouse his last student
somehow his gaze found preus who looked
so aged
and he says and i renounce my wife
as an adulteress and ah
his face a mask of nimble he turned to
that leave began walking back the way he
came
the men of the toss stared at him dumb
struck their outrage as bright as sparks
in their eyes but they fell before his
approach
they fell away
akamian calhouse said the next time you
come before me
you will kneel jesus akamian then the
book ends
retracing his bloody footprints the
wizard limped on
why is he a wizard he has no school he
is on his
own he has gone away and that's how the
whole thing
ends fittingly for
for the person who's been so central
in all of these events uh
akamian and how much of this has been
told through his
eyes and now we come to
another ending longer perhaps even you
could say
more momentous that which arises
out of the culmination of calhouse's
quest
which he used the holy war to pursue
finding his father and determining what
to do with him
this engagement will he kill his father
the way
that he was charged to do will he join
with his father his father
summoned him to do that will his father
replace him what will take place
so he meets his father and his father
at first there's a discourse where he
tells he sort of recaps
how adunyan takes control he says as
dunyan you had no choice
to command yourself you had to master
circumstance to master circumstance
you had to bind the actions of the world
born to your will
you had to make limbs of nations so you
made their beliefs the
the object of your relentless scrutiny
it was
axiomatic now that's interesting
he's saying listen you're one of the
conditioned and we're all trying to be
self-movers but really you couldn't have
done anything different than what you
did
he goes on and he has a whole bunch of
things about you know using the
nations their lies their their
stories all of those things you
understood that beliefs like men
possessed hierarchies that some
commanded better than others
that religious belief commanded most of
all what better
demonstration could there be than the
holy war itself so you read their
scriptures
scrutinized the authority of words over
men you saw the primary function
of anithism to anchor belief in what
cannot be seen
he goes on you know the god who becomes
the warrant of men in their station and
the arbitrary relations of power that
are the truth of the emperor and the
slave
are covered over and then
he says and here you saw the shortest
path you understood that this trick
which turns the eyes of the oppressed
skyward and away from the hand that
holds the whip
could be usurped to your ends to command
circumstance
you must command action to command
action you must command belief
to command belief you need only speak
with the voice
of heaven you are dunyane one of the
condition and they with these stunted
intellects were
no more than children so he says the
path was very narrow
but was very clear you cultivated their
own their inklings
telling them things no man could know
you appeal to the spark of logos within
them
you map the logic of their commitments
showed them the implications of the
tenets
they already held you showed them
beliefs fixed by truth rather than
function you made their fears and
weaknesses plain
you show them who they were even as you
exploited
these weaknesses to your advantage you
gave them purpose
though the world is anarchy
and throughout you insisted you were
only a man like any other
you conditioned so the dunyane
kalhus conditions these men and mengis
knows it because he's been doing this
his entire life on the outside as well
and he says even this wasn't enough
those of that authority lost nothing by
inserting you between them and their
gods
servitude is the most instinctive of
habits but those with authority
sooner or later the cast nobility had to
move against you crisis was inevitable
this he says was where the probability
trance
failed me and then calhouse introduces
something new into the mix
he says so you did not anticipate the
visions
his father's face remained absolute and
impassive
what visions and as it turns out
calhous is going to
have brought something new to the mix
that his father
can't grasp can't assimilate and has to
treat as madness
calhouse says the god he doesn't speak
to you
no curious manga says
and from where does his voice hail from
what darkness
calhouse says i know not thoughts come i
only know that they're not
mine another infinitesimal pause
he dips in the probability trance the
same as i
mangus the mads say much the same
perhaps your trials have
deranged you perhaps it's not in your
interest to deceive me
then calhoun says unless i've come to
assassinate you as our dunyan brothers
have decreed is this your apprehension
and he says
you have not the power to overcome me
but i do father
how his father finally said how could
you know this
because i know why you were compelled to
summon me
so you've grasped it yes the
thousand-fold thought the whole
the thing that the whole story is
supposed to be
about right we're going to come back to
this thousand-fold thought in a moment
but first
we need to talk about this possible
madness
and a little bit later this voice you
hear the old dunyan said is not part of
the thousand-fold thought
kel has ignored these words take me to
them to whom to those you hold
captive and
he's going to take him to see some of
the skin spies that his father has been
working upon we'll come back to that
part of the story
in just a bit because it's really
important to get to this
part about the the god
so the god
winds up being something outside of
the scope of the dunya just as much as
earlier they had thought there wasn't
sorcery we see that both kel huss
and his father encounter sorcery
master sorcery take use of it
but mengis has made some miscalculations
he in becoming a cesarean doesn't
realize that taking up the water
isn't going to work for somebody like
that so
here's what what kel huss tells him
you assume taking up the water would be
no different that becoming one of the
indara kashari would make you godlike in
comparison
and since the cesaro themselves scarcely
understood the metaphysics of their
practice
there was nothing you could learn that
would contradict this assumption you
couldn't know that the psuche was a
metaphysic of the heart not the
intellect
of passion so you let them blind you
only to find your powers proportional
to your vestigial passion something
where the dunya
actually are deficient what you thought
to be the shortest path was in fact a
dead end a dead end that will still
allow him to fight against
the consult but not effectively
going on he says about 12 years ago you
discovered the first of the consult skin
spies probably through discrepancies in
their voices the cesarean
were thrown into an uproar and then you
were dunyane
though our brothers know nothing of the
arcane our understanding of the mundane
is without pure you realize these things
weren't sorcerous artifacts
that they were engines of the flesh but
you couldn't convince the others
the other cesarem so that starts the war
between the cisarum and the scarlet
spires
but you kept the creatures and over
years of torment you broke them down you
learned of golgotharoth
her ramparts heaped around the horns of
an ancient derelict
a vessel fallen from the void in the
days when the non-men
yet ruled yarwa of the inquiry in the
great war they waged against long dead
non-men kings
you learn how the last survivors of that
fell race all wrong and
all rocks perverted the heart of their
non-man captor
mcketrig and how he corrupted the grand
master of the manga gaya in his turn
he goes on you learned of the consult
right and he says of course you heard of
the consult and you thought them long
dead
but the stories you extracted had too
much detail there was too much
consistency
the deeper you probed the more troubling
the story
became you learned that the boundaries
of the within the world and the outside
were not fixed
if the world could be cleansed of enough
souls it could be sealed shut against
the gods
against the heavens and hells of the
afterlife against redemption
and most importantly against the
possibility of damnation you the
consult you realize are laboring to save
their souls
so he goes on and they talk about the
second apocalypse of the probability
trance and the thousand-fold thought
once again so the question then
is is
is calhous insane the way his father
thinks that he is
i mean the dunyan have effectively
developed a psychology and philosophy
that's
beyond what we ourselves you know
even if we're working all of our time
and thinking the most dialectically ways
we can
beyond what we've achieved ourselves i
mean it's work of fiction so
it's easy to do that or is it that
the dunyan and their conditioning the
probability trance the thousand-fold
thought
all of these are in some respect
preparatory
for what kalhus is now becoming
because it's not just visions it's not
just the god speaking to him it's also
that no god
speaking to him as we find in his
discourse
with his father as well and if we go
further on
[Music]
here we go only a true son of israel
could succeed
for all the thousand-fold thoughts
innumerable deductions its elegance
there remain
countless variables that could not be
foreseen
each of its folds possesses a haze of
catastrophic possibilities most of them
remote
others nearly certain i would have
abandoned
it long ago were not the consequences of
inaction so absolute
only one of the condition could follow
its path only
you my son calhouse then says
you speak as if the thought were a
living thing
and manga says because it is and here he
brings in something interesting
have you heard of a game played in
southern nilamesh a game called
virus virum sata or many breaths
he says across the plains surrounding
the city of
invisi the ruling cast nobles are very
remote very effete
the narcotics they cultivate assure them
of the obedience of their populations
over the centuries they've elaborated
nyan this you know
etiquette to the point where it's
eclipsed their old faiths entire lives
are spent in what we might call gossip
but virus mata is
far different than the rumors of the
court of the clucking of harem eunuchs
far more they have made games of truth
they tell lies about who said what to
whom about who makes love to whomever
and so on they do this continually and
what is more there it pains to act out
the lies told by others
especially when they are elegant so they
might make them true
and it goes from tongue to tongue until
no distinction remains between what is a
lie and what is true
in the end a great ceremony is the most
compelling tale that is declared
versus a word that means this breath is
ground and ancient var
the parsi the weak the inelegant have
died while others go strong
do you see the virus mata they become
living things and we are their battle
plane
kalhuis nodded like in a in rithism and
phanemery
precisely lies that have conquered and
reproduced over the centuries delusional
worldviews that have divided the world
between them
they are twin virus mata that it now
wore through shouts and limbs of men
and the thousand-fold thought mangus
turned to him
precisely as if he could see an
instigator that goads them that bleeds
them
even as we speak a formula of events
that will rewrite the very course of
history
a great transition rule that we'll see
in rhythmism and phantom ray transform
the thousand-fold thought
is all these things
so he says and the truth calhouse said
what of that
there is no truth for the world born the
logos
for them is a tool of their lust nothing
more
and calhouse goes on and
uh mengis is is saying why
why my son why ask me what you already
know and so what what is actually
happening here
so if the thousandfold thought is
something
personified something living something
with agency and these other these other
faiths these other ways of looking at
things
are like that but sort of facsimiles of
it
that can be taken over then what should
calhouse do he should give himself
over to the thousand-fold thought right
now there's a very important thing that
happens
here here we go this is a little bit
later in their discussion
[Music]
says on the plains of mangetta the
sheryl knights what i prophesied
came to pass
to the world born these words would have
sent a blank devoid of concern
or occasion but to dunya and let him
think i waiver
a fortuitous correspondence of cause
mangus replied nothing more that which
comes before
yet determines that which comes after
how else could you have achieved all
that you have achieved
how else could you be possible so this
is the
you know regular dunyane approach to
things he was right
prophecy could not be but this is
something that that kel has already
figured out and worked through
in the earlier the earlier volumes right
if the ends of things govern their
beginnings if what came after determined
what came before
how could he have mastered the souls of
so many how could the thousand-fold
thought come to rule the three c's
the principle of before and after simply
had to be true if its presumption could
so in power his father had to be right
so what was this certainty this
immovable conviction
that he was wrong that his father was
wrong and he asked himself am i mad
mengis continues the dunyan think the
world close that the mundane is all
there is
and in this they are most certainly
wrong the world is open and our souls
stand astride its bounds
but what lies outside is no more than a
fracture and a distorted reflection of
what lies
within i have searched for nearly the
length of your entire life
i have found nothing that contradicts
the principle
he says the god sleeps it has been ever
thus only by striving for the absolute
may we awaken him meaning
purpose these words name not something
given they name
our task set aside your conviction
manga said for the feeling of certainty
is no more marker of truth
than the feeling of will is a marker of
freedom deceived men
always think themselves certain just as
they always think themselves free
kelos looked to the halos around his
hands
but we my son do not have the luxury of
error void void has come to this world
he's talking about the
uh the inicroy right and then the
consult
it fell from the skies thousands of
years past
and then calhouse says yes
the he speaks to me as well the no god
mengis asked he paused momentarily had
his father possessed
eyes callous was certain he would have
seen them fall in and out of focus his
consciousness within rose and submerged
then you truly are mad and
what what are the possibilities either
he must be
mad or
he must have seen something more
manga says the trial broke you you
confuse the madness within you for the
darkness without the same as the world
born
he's asking his father what is the no
god and his father won't answer
the darkness comes before you kelhus it
owns you you're one of the conditions
surely you
and then he sees that there's there's
others that are coming
he says i have been chosen father i am
the harbinger
his father calhouse realized had finally
grasped the principles of
the encounter that they would be doing
mengis had assumed his son would be the
one requiring instruction
he had not foreseen it as possible let
alone inevitable that the thousand-fold
thought here's the key
thing right here's the resolution
would outgrow the soul of its incubation
and discard it
so what does that mean kelhus
is the thousand-fold thought he
dominates it
he takes it and he doesn't need his
father
at this point his father and the the
dunyan could need him right he says
when you learn of the damnation that
awaits you when you come to believe
you'll be no different than the incario
as a dunyan you will be compelled to
master the consequences
of your witness wickedness like the
consul you'll come to see tyranny and
one is holy
and you will war as they war
and so he says for the dunyan it was
axiomatic
right um they they have to be
closing things off and he says perhaps
his father had yet to apprehend this
perhaps he couldn't see past the arrival
of his son or perhaps all this the
accusation of madness was simply a ruse
either way it was irrelevant you are
dunyine still father
as are and then here's the the key
the end i am more the warrior prophet
said
i am more i am
all of that all of the conditioning
all of those things and i also
have a grasp on sorcery
on prophecy on a different permutation
of the thousand-fold thought
that is what is going to allow kel huss
among these other things like possessing
the gnosis
to become the aspect emperor
in the thousand-fold thought we get to
learn quite a bit
more about both the incroy and the
unholy consult in fact we
find out that one of the original
members of the consult
is behind the synthesis that is that is
doing all sorts of stuff and engaging
particularly
with knier a lot of the revelations are
taking place
through the engagements of these
consult agents or agencies we could say
with the main characters and canar
is probably one of the most important
ones but as we're going to see kel huss
is as well
so one of the passages i want to focus
on
is when uh knighter is spending time
with the skin spies one of whom has
taken the
the guys uh and really in many respects
i guess you could say personality in
certain ways
of his former lover and prize stairway
so he says occasionally can i or spoke
to them learned something of their lean
ways they called themselves the last
children of the incari though they were
loathed to speak of their old fathers
they claimed to be keepers of the
inverse fire though the merest question
regarding either their keeping or their
fire
pitched them into confusion they never
complained
saved to say that they hungered for
unspeakable congress or to insist that
they were falling
always falling that's never really
followed up but it's an interesting
thing to say
they declared he could trust them
because their old father had made them
his slaves they were he
said dogs that would sooner starve than
snap meat from a stranger's hand
they carried kenair could see the spark
of the void
within them like the shrunk so the
shrunk you know
and the bashrog and i guess you could
even say the dragons they all
carry this this sort of voidness within
them and the skin spies
seem to as well there's a really great
explanation that's that's given here
as a child can i had been fascinated by
trees he saw them only in the winter
months
when they moved their camp into the
suaret the highlands that bounded
the sea the indrithi called jorya
sometimes he would stare at the bear
trees for so long they would lose their
radial dimensions and seem something
flat like blood smeared into the
wrinkles
around an old woman's eyes men were like
this
knight realized binding their manifold
roots then branching in a thousand
different directions
twinning into the greater canopy of
other men so you know there we're
talking about causality
about how we're all connected our
motivations
what binds us together and then he says
but these things these skin spies were
something altogether different although
they could mimic
men well enough they did not bleed into
their surroundings
as men did they struck through
circumstances rather than reaching out
to claim them they were spears
concealed in the thickets of human
activities thorns tusks
and this length of a curious beauty a
dread elegance they were simple in the
ways of knives these skin spies
he envied them that even as he loved and
pitied
and he goes on again and you know he's
a little bit later he's going to talk
about human beings
having been told by this sorcerer that
human beings are sort of like
pin pricks in a map and the skin spies
they're not like that their world is
essentially a sealed
one now later on towards
actually quite towards the end where my
thinnette becomes
a bit player character mythonet we
realize
is actually the half brother of callahus
because he was fathered by
mangus on his trip down to cheme
we find out that one of the sorcerers
belonging to the mandate
itself has been a skin
spy mythonet seizes him in this
conference between mithanet
and the cheryl knights and the
the mandate sorcerers the the quorum
simeon said go on limp as a kitten the
shira
held them with impossible strength and
then mythonet says
if you pinch them here they're
thoroughly incapacitated
now sarah says what is this madness
right
and my thing it says and if you wait
if you wait their true aspect will be
revealed
the old sorcerer struggled for his
breath there was something about the way
simeon shook something not
old something and so and then now sarah
says silence
mythonet says we learned of this one
through our interrogations of the others
it's an accident an anomaly that
thankfully
its architects have been unable to
recreate
and then now sarah says what are you
saying thrashing slack limbs the thing
called simeous began howling in a
hundred lunatic voices
my thing had braced his feet rocked like
a fisherman holding a twisting shark
now sarah stumbled back his hands raised
and warding with abject horror
he watched the man's oh so familiar face
crack open
clutch at the spies with hooked digits a
skin spy with the ability to work
sorcery
the shira of the thousand temple said a
skin spy
with a soul so even with these
creations of the
techne that the consult have been have
been doing
there's variations there's possibilities
there's differences
and this is quite an interesting one it
doesn't get followed up
because it is an anomaly now i mentioned
that
a lot of the engagements were with
knighter
and this happens because the skin spies
are being directed by
this synthesis and there are some very
important
conversations that are happening between
kanir
and the consult through this this
synthesis
so he talks about hearing the sound of
beating wings
he saw a raven descending in the dark to
the right of the skin spy
one corpse lay a skew a heap of others
its elbows bent out backwards its face
turned towards knight the bird landed on
its great cheek
it regarded him with a white human face
no larger than an
apple can i her curse stumble backward
what knew outrage
was this old the tiny face said in a
ready voice
old is the covenant between our peoples
knight said i belong to no people.
and then the synthes says perhaps but
something binds you to him you would not
have saved him otherwise
you would have not have killed my child
canair says nothing binds me
and then the bird says but the past
binds us all skil vendi as the bow binds
the flight of an
arrow all of us have been knocked raised
and released all that remains is to see
where we land
whether we strike true
and what is he saying there so the skill
vendi
among the races of men were the ones who
sided with the consult and the no god
and actually worship the no god
and have been fighting against other men
since
they are the people of war but now they
have been largely destroyed
and the consult is trying to bring him
in and the consult is also saying listen
we don't actually have a choice about
what we're
doing they're saying something kind of
similar to what kenair has realized
about calhous right so
he the he goes on and he says he came to
you didn't he the father of the warrior
prophet the dunyan
and he says the hunt is over tomorrow
the holy war
marches for shiraj and amateo i am to
remain behind
and then the synthetic says to him
you've been moved nothing more and
banjuka every move bespeaks a new rule
we are that new rule skill vendi
not even the dead escape the plate
so a little bit later in the
text there's another great conversation
between these two again
the bird comes down and
uh says you perplexed me skill vendi
can i er says demons not can i are now
new had many guises they were everywhere
mauling the world with their anarchic
appetites outraging
with their impersonations birds lovers
slaves and most of all
him he knows himself to also be in some
respects a demon
the bird tells him kill the occurred and
the dogs will be loosed why do you stay
your hand kill confisc
you know do your task
and can i hear says you speak to me of
killing when the dunyan's death should
be your only concern
and here we see that the consults have
misled themselves
he says the occurred plots the holy
war's destruction
we need the dunyan to find the other
mangus he's the greater threat
and then kanir calls him a fool and the
bird says i eclipse you mortal i am a
son of a more
violent race you cannot conceive of the
compass of my life and canair says why
the blood that pulses through my veins
is no less ancient nor are the movements
of my soul
you are not so old as the truth
and then canair goes on and says you
still do not understand them
before all the dunya are intellect i do
not know their ends but i know this they
make instruments of
all things and they do so with a way
beyond the ken of me
or even you demon and so
the bird says you think i underestimate
them and cair says
it's inevitable we are little more than
children to them
think on it bird mangus has dwelt among
the kianin for
30 years i know not your power but i do
know this he lies
far beyond it and
he says as you say skill vendi you know
not my power so you know the console is
very powerful it's been hiding for a
long time it's got all these
resources at its disposal and kanir says
to them
do you know what a dunyan would hear in
your words posturing
vanity weaknesses that betray your
measure and offer innumerable lines of
assault
a dunyan would grant your declarations
he would encourage you in your
confidence in all things
he would dispense flattering appearances
he would care nothing whether you
thought him your lesser your slave
so long as you remained ignorant
and the bird says ignorance of what
can i or spat your true circumstances
and what is what are the true
circumstances he says that you're being
played
you flounder in nets of your own making
the circumstances you struggle to master
bird have long again
long ago mastered you of course you
think otherwise like men
power stands high among your native
desires but you're a tool
as much as any man of the tusk
and then the bird says how then am i to
become my own instrument
can i or snorted for centuries you've
manipulated events from the dark so you
claim now
you assume that you must do the same
that nothing has changed
i assure you everything has changed you
think yourself hidden
but you're not chances are he already
knows you've approached me
chances are he already knows your ends
and your resources
even the ancient things can i realize
would suffer the holy war's fate
the dunyan would strip them the way the
people stripped the carcass as a bison
flesh for sustenance fat for soap and
fuel bone for implements
hide for shelter and shield no matter
how deep they ran the ages themselves
would be consumed
the dunyan was something new perpetually
new like lust
or hunger and so he tells the the
the incari in this synthesis
you must abandon your old ways bird you
must strike across trackless ground
you must surrender brute circumstance to
him because you cannot hope to match him
you must watch you must become a student
of opportunity
to kill him while you can and the bird
says
you know he is he's working our will
he's leading the holy war to sheme
and keniar calls him a fool and then the
bird says do you not
know who i am and you know shows him
with with this kind of glamour
and connier holds his his trinket his
his core eye
and says sorcery you're gonna toss
shanks to the walls of my argument
even as we speak he learns sorcery he's
actually learning
the mandate the most powerful of the the
sorceries available the the
the gnosis and here's where we see the
underestimation going
on he says um it will take him
years to learn that's what that
ultimately al-raeng
thinks and kanir says you forget
bird he learned my people's tongue in
four days if he can learn a language
he can learn sorcery and as we're going
to see
under akamian's tutelage and because of
his native ability
kelhus is actually able to take the
mandate
and its gnosis further than
any of the humans ever did taking it
beyond perhaps even what some of the
non-men who taught the gnosis
who were totally stained through and
through
with sorcery did
a little bit later on uh we actually get
a
point of view um
[Music]
chapter a sub-chapter with the
synthes and we find out it's who not
just one of the old names
one of the oldest of the old names one
of the most
important of those who fought
against the non-men against men who's
been directing things
part of the mandate all that time
he says here we go there had been a time
when he'd walked in glory and honor
spear
bearer to mighty sill the great king
after the fall
he dared the wrath of kujara kenmore on
the plains of pier pahal he'd ridden the
back of we're
father of dragons right he goes on
he was called the angel of deceit
and later called the warlord
aorang right so he says how he come to
this
bound to a synthetist like a king to a
leper's robe
fail and few frail and fugitives
skulking about the fires of a roused
enemy
there had come a time when the screams
of thousands and heralded his coming
and he goes on and talks about being
older than all of these things that are
going on
and then he also reveals why why they
want to use the holy war
for decades the consult had assumed the
alien metaphysics of the cesarean had
been responsible for uncovering their
children
in sheme this had made the prospect of
the empire's fall to the fondum
intolerable
the holy war seemed a rare opportunity
but the plate the banjuka plate where
they play this this game
had changed all too quickly to realize
that the cesaro more but a mask for a
far more ancient foe to come so very
close
only to discover their sublime deception
subverted by something deeper something
new
the dunyan there was more to this than a
sun hunting for his father
their devious methods and disconcerting
abilities aside
these dunyan were on a surim bore even
without the mandate prophecies enmity
was a fact of their cursed blood
so he goes on and says the skill vendi
had been right about one thing the
dunyan had seized too much already they
could not be allowed the gnosis
as well aorong uh
tells them to prepare the place and he
says the
ana surumbore marches the herotic way he
will pause before crossing the plane
revise his plans the skill vendi is
right he's come to realize that they
need to change their tactics
he isn't like the others a normal man
even
in on a suramar would succumb to the
eagerness that's so quick in the legs of
those who set upon a hard
one destination but not a dunyan
so he talks about uh here we go
before the the coming of these dunya and
the console could trust to their tools
now orang had no choice but to intervene
to tyrannize what the tools could only
mock
to possess what they could only mimic he
says
trust me children he'll be caught
unawares when we strike there is
treachery
in his wife's heart they would test the
limits of this prophet's penetration
they would try to deny him the gnosis
they don't succeed of course but there
is a passage here
where the synthes now comes in the guise
of essemet and i'm going to just
skip through this fairly quickly without
going into all the you know
descriptions of sexuality here the
consult had come
right and he says did you think akamian
stories could prepare you
what the mandate dream is but a sliver
of what i've lived
what i've seen i've walked in the know
god shadow i've looked across the void
and blotted your world by holding a
fingertip before it
no you know nothing of me or my kind and
then
calhouse says so what are you then
calhouse what are the incarroy
we are a race of lovers
the expected answer recollection cycled
through souls
not explicit and singular but implicit
and innumerable
everything akamian had said regarding
these abominations
he slackened his face in the simulacrum
of profound sorrow
and for this you are damned she says we
are born for damnation's sake
our very nature is our transgression
look at this exquisite body
i climb and enter because i must
and for this for for this i am to heave
and scream in likes of fire because of
boundaries
of skin and then calhouse says
denial is the way boundaries are written
into the order of things
and then she says but you you could
rewrite the scripture of my doom hum
prophet
he said and then he says there is no
absolution for your kind
so then would you destroy the world and
she says
to save my soul so long as there are men
there are crimes so long as there are
crimes i am damned
tell me dunyane what track would you
follow what would you do
to save your soul and then
she says love is the way and these
little demons you call god's decree
otherwise
dole out their rewards in proportion to
our suffering
no i would save my soul
and she tells him that his wife doesn't
smet doesn't truly love him she only
worships
right so she's trying to essentially
seduce him
and he ends up
pushing her away and engaging
in one of the awards one of the first
that akamian had taught him
right and he says across the world in
golgotharoth
the man mangakaya squad about your true
flesh
rocking to the mutter of endless cants
this synthesis the thing that you're
showing me right here is but a node
you are no more than the reflection of a
shadow an image cast upon the water of
essimet
you possess subtlety yes but you haven't
the depth to
confront me and
what do we see here calhouse is beyond
where the consult is trying to seek him
they're not really
able to make sense out of what he is
and that's probably the the theme that
we
could return to although i'm actually
we've already talked about this quite a
lot
in the other works so i'm going to
very quickly run through this and then
we'll talk about our
last philosophical theme so i can be
respectful of time
both knier and akamian come to realize
what the dunyan is and what kelhus is
not just in terms of his powers and
properties
not just in terms of the capacities that
being one of the conditions affords him
but the fact that they really are like
children to him being an adult
and that
he does not love he may feel
value he may feel all sorts of things
but deep down inside he does not love he
sees a greater
greater plan but love is only a tool
within it
and we see that akamian echoes what can
i er
points out and what the consult in a
certain sense
grasps but in a twisted way kenair says
they make
us love that's the greatest power of the
the dunyan is the capacity to to
you know bring people in
even estimate even uh akamian and
akamian
thinks that he's somewhat immune because
he's a critic he's standoffish he
doesn't believe he
he can see what's going on but even his
doubt
even his criticism
even his awe get drawn into him
becoming like it or not a tool
to the to the man the godlike man
who in effect cuckolds him and
takes from him the one thing besides
the mandate that he's stuck with that he
truly loves which is esimet
and the last thing that we should uh
talk about as a theme
is in fact the transformation that
happens with esimet
there is some very important exposition
about
the history including that of the
non-men
and the incare and the consult going
on in this depiction of what happens
once
essimet starts really studying
texts under kel huss's
you could say influence he's the one who
taught her how to read
she gets the books from akamian and
all of these allow her to to grow to
to add something new now of course
she's a very remarkable character to
begin with but
um i want to highlight a few
things here so
she's already been raised to power and
that itself is is
a very important difference she says
that woman
that sunni sunni harlot who hung her
legs bare from her window was a stranger
to her now
the trappings let alone fact of power
would be enough to make the old estimate
weep for wonder
but it's the reading that changes it
she says
the old estimate would never accept an
understanding
indistinguishable from trust but what
would strike the old estimate the most
she had no doubt would be the knowledge
in what in that one respect she'd been
extraordinary very few pondered their
ignorance as she had
their conceit compelled them to prize
only what they knew beforehand
and since significance followed from the
already known they
always thought they possessed everything
relevant any question of truth
she always understood that her world
for all its great immensity was a sham
that is why she'd made her custom into
apertures windows onto the world's
various corners
she'd used a camion as a doorway to the
past and now kalhus
and kel as she says has written the
world down to its very foundations
the old estimate would be astounded even
outraged but she would come to believe
eventually what we saw in earlier
books is that esimet when she was
illiterate
would use the men that she had sex with
as ways you know she's saying apertures
here
ways to get to know more about the world
asking them lots of questions piecing
together
something and then here we go like the
third analytic the sagas were one of
those works familiar even to illiterate
cast menials such as herself
she found it strange recalling her
impressions of such things before akami
and her calhouse
the ancient north she knew it always
seemed weighty and profound
a phrase with a palpable skin prickling
air right
she knew of the no god the apocalypse
the ordeal but they were little more
than curiosities the ancient north was a
place
something she could point to the times
akamian had mentioned the sagas he did
so only to dismiss
or to disparage for a mandate schoolman
he said they were like pearls strung
across a corpse
he spoke of the apocalypse and the no
god the way that others described
running arguments with their relatives
so going on a little bit further down
she said
the sagas had come to seem something
foolish perhaps even criminal
as much as she'd learned about the
apocalypse the fact remained that she
knew nothing about the sagas themselves
as works as texts the moment she
gingerly unrolled the first section of
scroll
that ignorance struck her with the
curious force of undone
deceptions despite the title she was
surprised to discover the sagas
consisted of a number of different works
written by different authors
though only two were named there were
nine sagas in total
some she would later discover were verse
epics while others were prose
chronicles she had no idea where kalos
had obtained the scroll
it was you know very nice and then you
know going on a little bit further
she found the going both difficult and
curiously erotic as though
aside from masturbatory solitude of
reading her struggle to accommodate the
writer's ancient assumptions
with something too intimate not to be
carnal right
she gathered that the dynasty of ana
sirimbor was old and venerable
even in those days of far antiquity and
now he talks about a transformation of
perspective
she goes on for some reason she'd always
thought of the first apocalypse as the
beginning of history rather than the end
of one and what's happening here
is she's gaining greater and greater
perspective
she says she realized that her
understanding of the old wars
was merely episodic now
she's beginning to understand all of
these
things and here we get the long
exposition
and what is happening here with
all of this she is developing
a greater knowledge by literacy by
reading by engaging with those who had
written in the past i think this is a
really
fitting place to end because we can say
something
i think analogous not the same but
analogous to
our own readings of these and
of other texts as well how much do we
learn when we
actually go and do the work of reading
the originals
and not simply relying on somebody
else's regurgitation
interpretation even worse
oversimplification and proof texting
as the ways the maps for
understanding our existence we do so
much better
when we go to the originals and
when we do the hard work and put in the
time
of reading and that can happen
with something that's even
a set of works of fiction a modern-day
epic of of sorts this is epic fantasy
after all of great imaginative but also
intellectual depth so
that is where we're going to conclude
all of this discussion that's been going
on now for
three sessions three straight months of
this great
prince of nothing trilogy by r scott
backer
[Music]
you